Today we are making some rocky road ice cream.
So I started off by making marshmallows.
I use gelatin leaves
and put them in cool water so that they could soften.
Then we started on a syrup, which was honey,
golden syrup, and sugar.
We separated some egg whites from the egg yolks,
started mixing those,
and then I added the softened gelatin leaves to the syrup,
added that to the merengue,
and it turned into this beautiful marshmallow whip.
It was so good, you guys.
So good. We started on the ice cream,
and I just scrape the cream off yesterday's milking.
I added the cream, chocolate, and then some whole milk,
and then we heated that up again.
I separated some more egg whites from the egg yolks
and added all those yolks in with some sugar,
beated that up,
and then we slowly added the warm mixed milk mixture to that.
Then we strain that just in case there was any bits of eggs.
We started chopping some chocolate and almonds.
We added it all to the ice cream maker and slowly added in the add ins.
The marshmallows turned out so good.
They were really delicious.
10 out of 10.
We added those to the ice cream while they were mixing as well,
and it turned out to be the best rocky road I've ever had.
It was so good.
We had it for lunch and dinner that night,
and then a little bit for breakfast.
The next morning